many people say one reason for the
increase in gun violence in this country
is the sheer number of firearms in
private hands according to the atf u.s
gun makers produced 11.3 million weapons
in 2020 more than half of them handguns
that's almost triple the number of guns
produced 20 years ago when firearms like
hunting rifles were more popular jeff
pigues spoke to nypd deputy commissioner
john miller about why there are so many
guns on the streets
from a shot fired at a convenience store
to a shootout on the street and stray
bullets killing kids police say that
they are seeing more guns on america's
streets than ever before some traceable
many not all of these were taken off the
streets all these weapon systems were
recovered off the streets of new york
atf special agent john devito and deputy
new york city commissioner john miller
say gun arrests are up in the city but
there is a bigger problem 80 percent of
the people we arrest with loaded guns in
the street
are not in jail or in prison 4 900
gun arrests last year alone only 17 of
them were prosecuted only 17 yeah
they believe a combination of factors
including backlogs in the courts caused
by covid
and bail reform are contributing to the
problem so that's a combination of
factors
including new laws in this state in new
york state that say
people should be released without bail
or if bail is to be set it has to be a
bail that the defendant can afford under
the least restrictive conditions
so you're seeing a lot of people
involved in gun crime who would have
been in who are out there is also a new
influx of weapons moving into new york
on what's sometimes called the iron
pipeline weapons with a higher bullet
capacity and more firepower i wish it
was a pipeline because a pipeline would
be easy to identify investigate and stop
what we have is an unknown number of
garden hoses
all over this country on a slow trickle
that are feeding the criminal
marketplace on a daily basis
and now there is also what they've
called the plastic pipeline plastic
ghost gun parts ordered online and built
at home
a tougher pipeline to shut down after a
recent raid police found a machine still
carving out new ghost gun parts to keep
up with what law enforcement believes is
currently an insatiable demand
we've seen ghost guns being produced in
very small apartments we've seen them in
basements we've seen them in closets you
really don't need much room to put these
guns together to combat the rise in gun
violence devito and miller say there has
to be a renewed focus on prosecution if
you arrest your way out of the gun
problem and people go to jail
then you're going to find your gun
problem is going to go down when you're
resting your way through the gun problem
and there is
no consistent consequence to people
carrying guns
you're going to see
what you're seeing now
which is people are not afraid to carry
people are not afraid to shoot there are
a lot of people in this country who feel
the more guns that are out there the
safer we're going to be statistics have
proven that to be wrong again and again
miller believes that there is a boom on
ghost gun orders right now because of a
new rule that will take effect in august
requiring that the plastic guns are
stamped with serial numbers to make it
easier to trace them if nate they're
used in a crime
i hear you on that jeff much more to do
when it comes to gun laws and gun safety
thank you so much